record numbers of migrants on the U.S
Southern border it's one of the most
politically charged issues being debated
ahead of the U.S midterm elections
critics say the politics playing out in
the U.S are also having a significant
impact on immigration policies across
the border in Mexico
it's not only policy the entire
migration situation
depends large politics and
human rights observers say that strict
border policies along with a recent
agreement between the U.S and Mexico to
contain migration has led to a pileup of
migrants in Mexico
Janina Ramos a program coordinator for
Doctors Without Borders says the
resulting crisis has left ngos with
limited resources in general we've seen
humanitarian consequences of politics
and that's something that we shouldn't
right because basic needs Primary Health
Care Mental Health
shelter food water shouldn't be linked
to a consequence of the politics
though Mexico City normally has the
space to accommodate large migrant
groups passing through the recent influx
of migrants has overwhelmed the
organizations that normally assist them
we're inside Mexico City's largest
migrant shelter in just the last few
weeks the migrant population here has
surged by more than five times the
shelter's capacity to say it's
overcrowded would be an understatement
and the shelter's organizers tell us
that more people are arriving every day
the shelter's director Sister Magda says
her organization has been in crisis mode
since last month after Mexico agreed to
accept more migrants being expelled from
the U.S
the shelter is on the verge of collapse
were short on water bathrooms we don't
even have enough food while many in
Mexico speculate over how the upcoming
U.S midterm elections will impact the
worsening crisis migrants are growing
concerned that border policies will only
become more strict
many families have entered the U.S but
many other families have been deported
to Mexico and have been sent back to
this shelter that's what worries me one
thing policy experts on both sides of
the Border say could provide some relief
to the migrant crisis is comprehensive
immigration reform from the U.S
government
that reform however is largely seen as
unlikely if the U.S Congress becomes
more divided after the midterm elections
Manuel rapalo Al Jazeera Mexico City